leute wir haben jetzt gerade noch einen
gesamtbestand von 482 eur 483 euro 3 hey
leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich
freue mich sehr heute endlich mal wieder
so ein video drehen zu können ich habe
das beim letzten mal auch gemacht da
habe ich nämlich 1 400 euro wisch
gutschein bekommen
dieses mal habe ich einen neuen
gutschein bekommen sogar 500 euro die
wir jetzt ganz entspannt hier ausgeben
können das ist noch so nice oder also
das habe ich mir als kind wirklich immer
gewünscht einmal 500 euro auszugeben für
irgendwas auf jeden fall machen wir das
heute damit es in zukunft auch wieder
coole videos geben wird auch so ist dass
man eben das ist ja wirklich ruhig p 500
euro ich würde sagen wie lange man gar
nicht lange abonniert auf jeden fall
sehr sehr gerne den kanal die videos
werden ziemlich nice hoffe ich mal und
ich lege jetzt mal los iphone also
ziemlich leid da muss ich nicht noch mal
bestellen ich habe ja dieses video
gemacht ich teste alle halter die sind
schon sehr original aus was aber neu ist
oder ich habe es noch gar nicht entdeckt
man kann hier unter marken shoppen und
dann kriegst du hier wirklich
anscheinend originale produkte von apple
oder sonstwem vorgeschlagen ich wollte
mir nämlich mein iphone bestellen was
dann halt wirklich auch original sein
kann also sollen ein originales iphone
von word ist gedacht dass das irgendwann
geht ich nehme einfach mal das
günstigste
kurz alter kann man hier 100 prozent
original apple iphone 4s es ist zwar
uralt für 26 euro nur eu und nehmen wahr
weiß okay 27 euro hey das ist trotzdem
verdammt günstig wenn ich das mal bei
google eingeben haben wir hier welche
für 80 990 105 das also da bin ich mal
gespannt was da an kommt machen wir auf
jeden fall schnell weiter ich wollte mir
nämlich mal so viele klamotten bestimmen
das haben so viele von euch sich
gewünscht und ich kriege so auf die nach
deswegen machen wir das jetzt einfach
mal den hier finde ich an sich ganz nah
sieht doch gut aus so ein schöner louis
wie gürtel was brauche ich denn da hab
ich trage fast ein viertel kaffeebraun
kommt war so kann man hier eine louis
wie keppler ich finde die nehme ich mal
in rot auch kaufen
okay hier haben wir gut ski schuhe
wer kennt sie nicht alter die direkte
heutzutage jeder oder nehmen da muss
jetzt mal korrigieren die sind nicht
gewesen 85 euro für diese alexander
mcqueens und das doch oder moment macht
also ich hab mir schon längst die haben
eigentlich 20 gekostet sind natürlich
auch nicht namens original reinigung
schon fertig leute ich hab nen neuen
saugroboter bekommen den würde ich euch
sehr gerne mal ganz kurz zeigen schaut
euch den unbedingt man da ist sogar eine
kamera bei einfach eine kamera im
saugroboter so leute maries gerade am
lernen und schön sauber und oder war das
laut als leben gefahren ist nein nein
konnte sich gut konzentrieren ist schon
mal gut läuft und zwar wächst die boss
not t8 awi zugeschickt das ist das
neueste modell auf markt und wie gesagt
da ist eine kamera mit bei der fed ist
ungefähr seit einer woche hier um man
muss sich da einfach abziehen und kann
halt darüber steuern korrekt heißt dass
wir selbst uns mal kurz die hin so sieht
das ganze auf jeden fall aus jeder
roboter ein qr-code dann kann man ihn
ganz einfach scannen und ihr habt
indirekt bei euch in der app integriert
und dann klickt man zb auf intelligente
reinigung und kann dann direkt hier die
ganze fläche also die ganze grundfläche
sehen und zum beispiel auch die letzte
reinigung ich habe ihn jetzt eben nur
dahinten das stück fahren
heute früh habe ein bisschen jetzt
konnte man hier draufklicken und dann
fährt er los
und der scan praktisch den ganzen raum
der fertig irgendwie nach chaos prinzip
man hört ihn ja auch kaum dass auf gut
also wer ist wirklich sehr leise ich
hatte ja auch schon mal andere sorgen
und da liegt jetzt wieder auf marie
danke fürs film ich bin okay leute ich
lege mich jetzt hier mal hin man kann
mit dem osmo g8 auch jederzeit einfach
von überall sein zuhause checken
das heißt wenn jetzt irgendwelche
einbrecher da unten werden oder marie
gerade lernt kriege ich hier auf
videomanager und gebt dann mein passwort
ein und jetzt können wir den raum ein
bisschen abfahren und schauen was die
marie so machen so fahren wir erst mal
von dem dock wegdrehen das ganze und da
sitzt marie da sitzt marie ein bisschen
zurück wieder könnt ihr sie erkennen
können wir fahren mal gegen sie also
wenn es zu irgendwelchen bewegung bei
euch im wohnzimmer kommt kann man das
hier direkt sehen so jetzt sprechen wir
mit marie hallo marina wie geht's also
das finde ich wirklich krass ich
verlinke euch den ausbau der a8 auf
jeden fall in der video beschreibung und
wir machen jetzt weiter mit dem video
ok 12 euro ok ich nehme das nl und farbe
wenn das nur 214 komm ich habe es jetzt
in orange einfach mal gekauft finde ich
cool ich hatte noch nie ein eigenes
style and peace deswegen aubert sei
wunderschön t shirt nl farbe gelb 9 euro
da kann man sich doch nicht beschweren
dass kaufen wird so was ich jetzt noch
haben wollte war gut ski schuhe die
gucci schuh die braucht man nämlich vor
allem in köln sehr viele leute in shisha
bars und so tragen diese schuhe
das ist ganz ganz wichtig dass man ja
die frage ist wo sind sie also da hätte
ich jetzt gedacht dass es hier mehr
auswahl gibt aber anscheinend nicht
es gibt tatsächlich nur die hier aber
besser als gar nichts oder in 43 und
weiß und gold 21 euro da kann man sich
nicht beschweren
die nehmen waren ich gehe einfach mal
ganz entspannt die die express page
runter ob es da irgendetwas gibt was ich
haben könnte oder bräuchte oder euch gut
zeigen könnte august diese lampe habe
ich letztes mal für 80 gekauft hier
kostet die nur 26 ist das ist
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schlechtere
qualität heute ich suche auf jeden fall
jetzt gerade
so heißen valencia wo die weil die sind
ja voll im trend
valencia wo die als wenn es hier kein
gibt das ist super schade
den hätte ich nämlich sehr gerne gekauft
ja gut hier habe ich jetzt noch nicht
teilen die jacke gefunden
und irgendwie ist es schwierig also es
gibt viel von louis vuitton es gibt die
ein oder andere sache von gucci aber der
rest ja was ist das denn ihm war den
hier einfach mal oder ich hoffe ich
spreche das jetzt richtig aus maine
paris da wird mir auf jeden fall die
ganze zeit angezeigt auch in schwarz 13
euro da kannst du nicht meckern los
genau ich habe zwar schon ultralange
keine airports mehr getestet wollte ich
auch nicht mehr machen aber ich wollte
wenigstens noch mal schauen ob sich da
was neues entwickelt hat war vor fünf
sechs monaten hat man airport pro fakes
nicht unter 40 euro bekommen eigentlich
und hier gibt es jetzt halt tatsächlich
schon für 14 euro
sie können die haut kommen nämlich mit
als hätte sich hier schon so lange dran
und bin geraten aber 200 euro
ja da geht noch was okay leute ich habe
einen kleinen cut gemacht und zwar habe
jetzt einfach mal so ein bisschen weiter
geschockt ich zeig euch jetzt mal die
ganzen sachen die hier noch im warenkorb
gelandet sind wo wir sind mittlerweile
bei 400 auf jeden fall deutlich über 400
euro erstmal muss ich sagen habe ich
gerade noch 10 kostenlose items in den
warenkorb gelegt also man musste er bei
denen immer den versand bezahlen da gibt
es wirklich so viele verrückte dinge wir
haben ja eine fliegenfalle also kann man
wie das aussieht ich weiß nicht ich kann
damit wahrscheinlich nichts anfangen
aber ich habe das einfach mal bestellt
weil ich hätte habe so was noch nie
gesehen sieht interessant aus und
vielleicht funktion jetzt ja wirklich
weil ich habe schon oft fliegen hier
drin also die ganzen kostenlosen artikel
zeige ich euch jetzt mal nicht was wir
jetzt auf jeden fall noch bestellen und
zwar wisse ja ich ziehe bald um in eine
neue wohnung hier und ich hätte gern so
neuesten led hintergrund mit möglichst
vielen leds 1 wir haben schon hier im
hintergrund wir haben einmal den blitz
den ich auf der kamera wirklich cool
findet das open schild was schon ewig
dabei ist all diese lampe da gut das ist
kein e on seien aber wir haben jetzt
noch folgendes hier zu bestellen und
zwar leute gebt euch mal diese banane
hier die finde ich ultras ich glaube er
könnte sehr gut im hintergrund passen
die kaufen wir auf jeden fall schon
markt dann habe ich mich jetzt noch dazu
entschieden hier dieses lolli zu kaufen
wo ist hier natürlich muss man ein
bisschen die farben beachten als ich
will auch nicht zu viele verschiedene
farben nehmen mehr so den fokus auf lila
und blau setzen hat ja bis jetzt ganz
gut geklappt dann habe ich dieses schild
hier in pink oder lila wie man möchte
bestellt ultra geil
also für 17 euro zählen com das hat
sogar eine maße von 40 zu 30 cm
das wird so nice dahinter und also ihr
könnt euch darauf freuen gut ich will
jetzt nichts garantieren weil es ist
immer noch was aber ich glaube das
können cool werden diese ernährung ble
zeiten ist auch von bush glaube ich dann
möchte ich hier noch die wolke bestellen
in blau
genauso wie sie hier abgebildet ist und
als kleiner kontrast dazu hier diesem
stern in
warm white das und dann vielleicht doch
den mond wir belassen es erstmal man
sollte auch nicht zu viel machen
dann hab ich mir noch folgendes überlegt
und zwar gibt es ja jetzt bald auch
neues auto ich weiß nicht ob ihr das bei
instagram mitbekommen haben oder ob ich
mir da überhaupt volk falls nicht sehr
gerne ich hatte einfach alex w da freue
ich mich schon sehr drauf und ich hab
mir gedacht ich mach einfach mal so
karadzic das hier sieht interessant aus
wird gekauft also reinigungs zeug gut
ich weiß nicht ob ich damit jetzt an
mein neues auto dann gehe er nicht aber
ich nehme es einfach mal mit dann haben
wir hier noch so ja ich brauch bmw ganz
in diese getränke verschattung sieht
finde ich cool aus an hier so eine
rückenmassage fit fürs auto ja da kommt
kaufmann bin ich mal gespannt ob mich
das überzeugt man kann das hier auch für
den bürostuhl benutzen
dann haben wir hier noch eine
klimaanlage die ich persönlich nicht
brauche weil ich habe eine klimaanlage
aber für leute die keine klimaanlage
haben würde ich die matte ssten ich weiß
nicht wenn ich jetzt noch was findet
dann nehme ich das auf jeden fall auch
mit rechnung planer bitte nicht bloß
nicht alter leute wir haben jetzt gerade
noch einen gesamtbestand von 482 eur 483
euro 3 habe ich das jetzt richtig
berechnet auf jeden fall wird das jetzt
alles bestellt und ich hoffe es kommt
schnellstmöglich an alter das ist ja
geil und ich es geht nicht mal von
meinem konto ab
gebt euch mal die ganzen sachen die ich
kaufe alter ok weiter afag warte mal
muss ich nicht noch die adresse ändern
deine bestellung ist unser weg hier
sieht man es noch mal wobei ich das
verliere ja leute das war's ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen lassen doch nach oben
da checkt die videos abgekommen werden
abonniert gern auch einen neuen kanal
alex v und wir sehen uns dann mittwoch
wieder gibt's neues video wobei ich es
in zukunft auch ziemlich viel zu tun hab
mit umzug und auto und alles was sich
verändert aber ich gebe mein bestes und
nicht sagen
[Musik]